[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin ihnen allen einen schönen
guten abend katja stresow zeigt uns
heute was vor sich los ist mache ich
sehr gern genannt und das sind unsere
themen des tages
krisendiplomatie in kiew außenministerin
wer bock sagt der ukraine unterstützung
im konflikt mit russland zu waffen soll
es aber nicht geben
kippt der § 209 10 a justizminister
buschmann will dass ärztinnen und ärzte
sachlich über möglichkeiten zur
abtreibung informieren dürfen
und jetzt wird in australien tennis
gespielt alexanders wäre ist nach der
abschiebung von novak djokovic einer der
favoriten und gewinnt auch gleich
[Musik]
herausfordernde tage für deutschlands
außenministerin berbalk mitten im
aufgeheizten russland ukraine konflikt
trifft sie die außenminister beider
länder heute kiew morgen moskau seit
wochen lässt russland mit massiver
militärpräsenz die säbel rasseln ein
einmarsch wird befürchtet die
internationale diplomatie hat bislang
wenig erreicht annalena baerbock
sicherte unterstützung zu die ukraine
verstehen darunter allerdings etwas ganz
anderes als deutschland andreas kienast
ordnete sein die himmlischen 100 nennen
sie in kiew die 100 menschen die auf dem
majdan ihr leben ließen 2014 als sich
die ukraine für europa entschieden wird
mit blut schmerz und endloser trauer
bezahlten dass die deutsche
außenministerin nicht gleich nach moskau
sondern zuerst nach kiew und in kiew
zuerst zu den himmlischen 100 kommt ist
bei vox wichtigstes signal niedergelegt
in der ukraine aber gerichtet an moskau
kein land hat das recht
anderen ländern vorzuschreiben in welche
richtung es gehen welche beziehung es
haben und welche bündnisse ist eingehen
darf
angesichts der drohungen der ultimaten
aus moskau angesichts der 100000
russischen soldaten die an der
ukrainischen grenze stehen sagt berbalk
außenminister cholera die solidarität
und die unterstützung deutschlands zu
die ukraine weiß was damit nicht gemeint
ist so sehr sie auch auf ihre geschichte
verweist die lieferung von
verteidigungswaffen lehnt die
bundesregierung ab
wir wissen wofür wir waffen brauchen wir
brauchen sie ausschließlich für die
verteidigung unseres hoheitsgebiets
berbalk begründet dass nine mit der
restriktiven rüstungsexportpolitik
aufgrund der deutschen geschichte
nichts von dem was die ukraine am
dringendsten haben will ist deutschland
bereit zu geben deutschland ist gegen
die lieferung von defensivwaffen
deutschland ist gegen den nato-beitritt
der ukraine und deutschland ist gegen
den sofortigen stopp von nord stream
zwei diplomatie sagt berbalk sei der
einzig gangbare weg morgen in moskau
will sie für ein gipfeltreffen zwischen
den präsidenten putin und sie lenski
werben moderiert von deutschland und
frankreich
morgen trifft berbalk also auf russlands
außenminister lavrov christiansen moskau
gab es dort schon also in moskau
reaktionen auf das heutige treffen
eine offizielle reaktion auf das treffen
gab es heute noch nicht ich denke man
hat sich das hier im kreml in ruhe
angeschaut wie der tenor war denen die
außenministerin die deutsche
außenministerin bei ihrem treffen in
kiew gesetzt hat und so wird man dann
morgen in die gespräche gehen und der
tenor der gesetzt wurde ist ganz klar
deutschland steht an der seite der
ukraine auch wenn viele forderungen der
ukraine nicht erfüllt wurden jetzt wird
annalena baerbock hier die gespräche
morgen haben sie wird das mit sergey
lavrov zu tun bekommen dem russischen
außenminister seit 2004 ist der
außenminister und er ist ein erfahrener
außenpolitiker ist geradezu berüchtigt
dass er seine gesprächspartner gerne
auch mal auflaufen lässt auch vor
laufenden kameras
und das wird interessant zu beobachten
sein wie die stimmung in diesen
gesprächen morgen hier sein wird
russland beharrt weiter darauf
sicherheitsgarantien zu bekommen die hat
russland nicht bekommen auch nach dem
gesprächsmarathon in der vergangenen
woche und annalena baerbock wird
ihrerseits auch noch einmal versuchen
ganz deutlich die positionen
deutschlands europas und der nato klar
zu machen und da ist wenig spielraum für
kompromisse vielen dank nach moskau
christian senn verspricht also spannend
zu werden morgen seit einer stunde
beraten die gesundheitsminister von bund
und ländern über corona vor allem wie
man weiter für impfungen werben kann und
wie sich omikron auswirkt die neue
virusvariante hat das infektionsrisiko
ja komplett verändert auch darum gilt
für alle nun die eine krone infektion
überstanden haben dass ihr genesenen
status von 6 auf jetzt drei monate
verkürzt wird alexandra vacano beginnt
ihren bericht mit einer besonderen
infektion
klar der arzt setzt selbst die spritze
an der gesundheitsminister heute zu
besuch im impfzentrum in schwerin auch
wenn omikron wohl milder verläuft ist er
ein klarer befürworter der impfpflicht
bundesgesundheitsminister muss man
respektieren wenn an entscheidung eine
gewissensentscheidung des parlamentes
ist dann machen die abgeordneten
vorschläge und nicht der minister oder
der bundeskasse impfen appelliert
lauterbach damit im herbst nicht wieder
über einschränkungen oder gar über einen
look down diskutiert werden müsse große
sorge um die korona zahlen die weiter
steigen laut lka gab es 34.000 145
neuinfektionen
8890 mehr als vor einer woche die sieben
tage incidents wieder ein neuer
höchstwert bundesweit 500 28,2 bei
omikron gibt es seit ende 2021 einen
steilen anstieg der fälle heute wurden
mit neun
1968 mehr fälle gemeldet als am vortag
das sind 5 prozent mehr deshalb die
warnung des gesundheitsministers vor dem
treffen mit seinen länder kollegen und
kollegen am abend das ist aber kein
grund für entwarnung gibt und dass wir
daher den kurs den wir derzeit fahren
auf jeden fall weiter fahren müssen
möglicherweise noch einmal verschärfen
müssen je nachdem wie es sich in den
nächsten zehn tagen verändert wie
umgehen mit den rasant steigenden corona
zahlen darüber diskutiert zur stunde die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz ergebnisse
in knapp einer stunde
ja und dann zdf spezial beschäftigt sich
heute mit der frage immer neue
höchstwerte wie gefährlich ist omikron
direkt im anschluss an unsere sendung
und wie hoch ist die aktuelle incidents
in ihrer stadt oder ihrem landkreis das
und mehr erfahren sie in unserer zdf
heute app
kinder gelten zwar nicht als pandemie
treiber sind aber auch betroffen von der
mikrowelle und so stellt sich dann für
jedes bundesland gerade die frage des
pflicht für kitas ja oder nein in
deutschland sind rund 2,8 millionen
kinder zwischen 1 und 6 jahren in kita
betreuung in ländern wie baden
württemberg und bayern gilt die
testpflicht schon dort muss meist per
lolli mehrmals die woche geprüft werden
ob die kinder sich angesteckt haben
andere länder wollen in den nächsten
wochen nachziehen bremen entscheidet
wohl morgen von dort berichten kai
niklasch und route kann
wie gefährlich eine ansteckung mit
corona sein kann erlebte die erzieherin
nadine runow 2020 aus eigener anschauung
noch heute leidet sie unter den
langzeitfolgen meine größten probleme
die ich noch habe sind einfach die
atmung so also gerade wenn ich irgendwie
nicht darauf achte fällt mir das sehr
schwer
dann fange ich an ganz kurzatmig zu
werden so und habe ich kognitiv halt
einschränkungen irgendwie immer noch im
land bremen soll nun aufgrund der hohen
zahlen von neuansteckungen mit der
omicron variante noch diese woche eine
testpflicht für kinder in
kindertagesstätten verabschiedet werden
wir fänden es gut wenn sie an der
tatsächlich gäbe wir testen ja eh schon
regelmäßig aber halt noch auf
freiwilliger basis aber in den schulen
wird ja auch getestet das ist nicht
freiwillig sie müssen ich fand es für
die kinder auch angemessen wenn
natürlich lolli tests für die kleinen
dann auch bereit gestellt werden dann
finde ich das auf jeden fall eine gute
sache das kauen auf einem watte starb
beim lolli test für die kinder einfacher
als ein nasenabstrich die ausbreitung
der omicron variante greift unterdessen
weiter um sich in niedersachsen mussten
heute kitas schließen weil in manchen
gruppen die hälfte der kinder und über
ein viertel der mitarbeiter erkranken
diese omikron variante ist ja eine diese
hier ansteckend ist und folge der sind
verbreitet sich das ruckzuck und da
waren hier aufgefordert durch das
gesundheitsamt eben auch aber auch
selber als träger das so schnell wie
möglich zu unterbrechen und
infolgedessen haben wir die kitas
geschlossen auch auf andere bundesländer
könnt ihr damit der druck wachsen auf
die jüngsten entwicklungen mit einer
testpflicht und
arg abend in deutschland wieder
demonstrieren in zahlreichen städten
gegner der korona maßnahmen teils
widerrechtlich in magdeburg trafen sich
etwa 500 menschen zu unangemeldeten
sogenannten spaziergängen zuvor hatte
die polizei mehr als 200
betretungsverbote für die altstadt
erteilt im zentrum gab es eine
gegendemonstration wie auch in vielen
weiteren städten in köln gingen
ebenfalls hunderte maßnahmen gegner auf
die straße bislang blieb es friedlich
der weitere verlauf der korona pandemie
könnte auch entscheidend für die
wirtschaftliche entwicklung in china
seien zuletzt hatten dort neue omikron
fälle für unruhe gesorgt im vergangenen
jahr ist die wirtschaft noch deutlich
gewachsen um 8,1 prozent ein grund dafür
waren die starken exporte die krise in
der immobilienbranche
gestiegene rohstoffkosten und
energieknappheit könnten sich aber
negativ auf die konjunktur auswirken
schätzen experten
apropos konjunktur und finanzen vii
finanzminister lindner ist damit auf
europäischer ebene halten wird ist eine
der spannenden fragen die man sich in
brüssel stellt eine vergemeinschaftung
von schulden hat deutschland anders als
zb frankreich bislang abgelehnt und so
will es lena wohl gerne beibehalten
ob französischer charme hilft den kurs
zu ändern bleibt abzuwarten florian a
der französische finanzminister spricht
gerade in brüssel vor den kameras da
entdeckt er seinen neuen deutschen
kollegen hallo wie geht's
man kennt sich ich muss auf französisch
sprechen leider man duzt sich in der
gruppe der finanzminister der euro
staaten und kann doch heftig streiten
etwa über die schuldenregeln der
eurozone kaum ein finanzminister kam
eine finanzministerin kann hier noch
vermelden die grenze etwa bei der
gesamtverschuldung einzuhalten sollte
man sie daher auf weichen der neue gibt
sich rhetorisch offen inhaltlich aber
zugeknöpft wir wollen uns die vorschläge
anderer staaten ansehen die regeln des
stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes haben
allerdings auch für die bürgerinnen und
bürger eine hohe bekanntheit und eine
hohe verlässlichkeit
deshalb ist meine erwartung nicht dass
dort grundlegende veränderungen
realistischerweise zu erwarten sind
frankreich erhält die regeln für
überholt und zugleich bröckelt die
gruppe der sparsamen die ebenfalls neue
niederländische finanzministerium
spricht jedenfalls kaum noch über
schulden können
die niederlande haben sich bewusst für
mehr investitionen entschieden es war in
den kampf gegen den klimawandel
sieht realitäts bleibt sollte doch
zuerst ein pakt des wachstums sein ich
würde sagen wachstum kommt vor
stabilität
es wird eine harte diskussion in der
euro-gruppe muss christian lindner sich
wohl erst noch verbündete suchen
frauen und mädchen sollen sich in
zukunft leichter über schwangerschafts
abbrüche informieren können bisher
verbietet genau dass der paragraph 219 a
die ampel koalition will ihn ersatzlos
streichen heute der erste schritt
justizminister buschmann legte dazu
einen entwurf vor ärztinnen und ärzte
sollen dann auch auf ihren
internetseiten sachlich über
schwangerschaftsabbrüche aufklären
können lars montag berichtet für sie
könnte bald ein kampf zu ende gehen die
ärztin christina hat jahrelang dafür
gestritten dass der paragraph 219 a
gestrichen wird wenn der paragraph 219
angestrichen es bedeutet das dass
ärztinnen ärzte die zu hunderten
angezeigt worden und die informationen
alle von der webseite genommen haben
wieder ausführlich ihre pflicht nämlich
zu informieren und damit zu einer
informierten entscheidung der
betroffenen zukommen nachzukommen hähnel
und viele andere ärzte und ärztinnen
wurden gerichtlich belangt weil sie auf
ihren webseiten über ihre arbeit und
mögliche methoden bei abtreibungen
informiert hatten der § 209 10 a der das
verbietet soll nun komplett gestrichen
werden damit eröffnet sich für frauen in
einer schwierigen
gewissensentscheidungen in einer
schwierigen lebenssituation ein weiterer
sachlicher informationskanal eine neue
informationsquelle mit sachlichen
information und das ist im jahr
2022 bitter nötig und angebracht die
union ist strikt dagegen das sogenannte
werbeverbot für schwangerschafts
abbrüche aufzuheben
wenn wir dir das werbeverbot für
abtreibung bestreichen dann gibt es
nicht nur änderungen auf der homepage
von ärzten sondern dann kann für
abtreibung geworben werden wir jetzt für
schönheitsoperationen nur dafür
augenlasern geworden wird der widerstand
nur von union und fdp zu erwarten ist
gilt eine mehrheit für die streichung
des paragrafen 219 als sicher
mehr als viereinhalb jahre verhandelte
ein türkisches gericht den fall der
deutschen journalisten michael tornow
nun ist sie in abwesenheit
freigesprochen worden ende april 2017
war toll in istanbul festgenommen worden
und saß mehr als sieben monate in
untersuchungshaft
zeitweise mit ihrem kind die
staatsanwaltschaft hatte ihr die
mitgliedschaft in einer
terrororganisation und terror propaganda
vorgeworfen jalloh war 2018 nach
deutschland zurückgekehrt
schöne kleidung muss nicht unbedingt
teuer sein das beweist nicht zuletzt die
beliebtheit diverser großer ketten die
jeans shirts und jacken günstig anbieten
aber oft ist es um die nachhaltigkeit
nicht gut bestellt neben schlechten
bedingungen für baumwollpflücker oder
näherinnen ist auch die umweltbilanz der
produkte nicht optimal rund um die
frankfurter fashion week etwa ist ein
gegentrend spürbar es wird mehr lokal
und umweltfreundlicher hergestellt auch
wenn das wohl höhere preise bedeutete
markus wolsiffer
eine ganze kollektion made in germany
rene stark ist vorreiter in sachen
nachhaltigkeit der designer aus
frankfurt produziert ausschließlich in
deutschland
langlebige stoffe und kurze
transportwege weniger umweltbelastung
und faire arbeitsbedingungen darauf
kommt es ihm an ich denke dass unser
bewusstsein geschärft werden sollte und
das ist das woran wir arbeiten eben
genau zu gucken was wir konsumieren und
wie wir es konsumieren und vichy wird
tatsächlich brauchen
nachhaltigkeit ein thema auf der
frankfurter fashion week die pandemie
bedingt nur teilweise in präsenz
stattfindet mit ihren konferenzen und
ausstellungen will die branche zeigen
dass sie um denkt eine umfrage zufolge
planen 92 prozent der deutschen textil
unternehmen mehr nachhaltige produkte zu
verwenden zum beispiel bio baumwolle
ich würde es gar nicht mal als trend
bezeichnen sondern es ist ein weg in die
zukunft ein zurück für nachhaltigkeit
gibt es gar nicht mehr es wird nur noch
ein ja ein weiteres fortschreiten von
nachhaltigkeit geben bis dahin ist es
ein langer weg 25 prozent aller weltweit
eingesetzten insektizide werden allein
für den baumwollanbau genutzt es ist
zeit dass dass sich die unternehmen auch
dieser verantwortung die sich auch haben
bewusst werden und nicht einfach sagen
na ja gut wir exportieren letztendlich
unseren fußabdruck und wir sind da nicht
für verantwortlich
nachhaltigkeit dürfe deshalb nicht nur
ein marketing es laufen sein findet
designer rene stark auf das die branche
es ernst meint mit ihren bemühungen
so gut geht jetzt sportlich mit katar
weiter und beim tennis geht es wirklich
um tennis backovic ist inzwischen in
seiner heimat belgrad angekommen und
derweil haben am ersten tag der
australian open in melbourne fünf
deutsche tennisprofis die zweite runde
erreicht drei sind ausgeschieden einer
von ihnen daniel meier der im deutschen
duell ging alexander zverev ran muss das
wäre einer der favoriten auf den
turniersieg gewann mit etwas mühe mit 7
zu 6 6 1 und 7 zu 6 als alexander zverev
dieses zähe match beendet hatte nach
einem schlag ins netz von daniel
altmaier dann merkte er erst mit
verzögerung dass dieser fünfte matchball
endlich der gewinnbringende war also vor
ans netz zum in drei sätzen bezwungen
gegner ein ungleiches duell war es im
dritten satz nicht mehr als wäre es
konzentration nachließ und sein
deutscher konkurrent die nummer 89 der
welt über kampf zu gutem spiel fand
daniela altmaier verdiente sich respekt
doch wenig später bekam es wäre auf den
schlussapplaus
verdienter applaus auch für mona
skifahrerin anna lena forster bei der
parade wm in lillehammer norwegen gewann
die 26-jährige heute ihre dritte
goldmedaille dieses mal in der super
kombination und in der stehenden klasse
gab es noch eine wm bronzemedaille durch
anna maria rita im slalom bei der
deutschen handball-nationalmannschaft
hat es den nächsten positiven corona
fall gegeben hendrik wagner der für den
positiv getesteten julius kühn als
nachrücker angereist war ist ebenfalls
infiziert wagner hatte aber noch keinen
kontakt mit der mannschaft die gestern
abend für ihr zweites vorrundenspiel bei
der em gegen österreich mit 34 29
gewinnen konnte es sind die widrigkeiten
mit denen trainer wie alfred gislasson
dieser tage klar kommen müssen hendrik
wagner gerade erst im hotel in
bratislava angekommen steht nun also
auch nicht zur verfügung ich habe das
gleich beim beim mittagessen durchgesagt
männer ihr alle negativ glücks natürlich
weiß ich aber dass endlich da ist ein
träges leiter positiv ein neuerlicher
dämpfer nach der vorzeitigen
qualifikation für die hauptrunde
julius kühn dem zweiten positiv
getesteten geht es aktuell in seinem
quarantäne hotel den umständen
entsprechend recht gut
am morgen dann das nächste gruppenspiel
es geht um den gruppensieg gegen polen
von 17.45 uhr live im zdf dankeschön
katja und wir haben was schönes für
wetten dass fans sie dürfen jetzt jubeln
weil der showklassiker hier im zdf geht
in eine weitere runde thomas gottschalk
moderiert dann in diesem und nächstem
jahr wie eine show und sicher mit vielen
stars auf der couch mit cleveren kindern
und natürlich wie immer mit skurrilen
ideen und vorschläge dafür sind ab jetzt
willkommen
und ich glaube ich kann auch sagen es
bleibt kalt in der nacht gibt jedenfalls
regen es gibt schnee morgen wird es ein
bisserl ruhiger mehr dazu gleich von
osten tel wir empfehlen ihnen später
bettina schausten um 21 uhr 45 mit dem
heute journal morgen abend werden wir
uns ausnahmsweise einen tick früher in
der handball halbzeitpause gegen 18 uhr
40 das war es von uns hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit dem zdf spezial und das
gesamte 19 uhr heute team wünscht noch
einen entspannten montagabend
[Musik]
schon gut wieder spielt hoher luftdruck
eine große rolle vor allem im westen
europas das hoch dehnt sich aus aber
noch müssen wir diese kaltfront hier
ertragen die zieht in der nacht
südostwärts und bringt durchaus noch
regen und schnee und so sieht das aus
vor allem den mittelgebirgen fällen
fallen schneeflocken sonst gibt es regen
das ganze zieht südostwärts im osten da
klart es auf und es wird dort am
kältesten seien mit temperaturen bis
minus 3 grad 6 grad mild ganz im westen
deutschlands
morgen gibt es in der norddeutschen
tiefebene viele wolken zu etwas regen
sonst zeigt sich auch mal die sonne den
meisten sonnenschein gibt es an den
alpen und im südwesten deutschlands wird
erwarten seien dann morgen an den alpen
mit zwei grad so ähnlich wie im vogtland
deutlich milder richtung rheinland mit 8
grad die kommenden tage am mittwoch gibt
es im nordwesten regen sonst aber auch
mal sonnige abschnitte im süden bei ein
bis sieben grad und am donnerstag geht
das ganze in schnee über höchstens im
rheinland zu regen dazu viel wind aus
dem norden ja dass bei null bis sechs
grad damit wünsche ich ihnen ein schöner
abend